you're talking to
to joe rogan on his podcast about how
like uh that fighting um
they did that you could it was like an
animal party that you couldn't
like let lose the the
and then you just said [ __ ] it i'm gonna
let it loose i don't know i guess um
i never knew how much good i could do
doing how many people i could help doing
it yeah it's just um
for me to fight and buy another house or
a plane or
whatever a dog or a cat whatever
to buy anything right it just doesn't do
it anymore all right
you know that doesn't do it for me
anymore but if i can help
what i spend on myself if i can help
i don't know 10 000 people that would be
awesome wouldn't that sound more awesome
helping 10 000 people
than one one is it the big screen tv
or feeding a village of ten thousand
people
yeah yeah isn't that a trip yeah when'd
you come up with that realization
i have a son um and um
he goes to haiti and build dams and lay
and i'm afraid to go to haiti and this
guy's only 18 he's been there five times
slept over this state over there know
the people and i said hey i have to go
too
how could this guy have more balls than
me he's only 17 years old
yeah balls are uh i think you do just
fine because he risked his life just to
help people he don't even know
yeah yeah soul mission foof god
yeah dude